[Applaudissements]
allez on va on va regarder un petit peu
ce qu'il fallait pas louper à la télé
alors ai dit ça je sais que vous aimez
bien la télé vous toi jamais vous
regardez beaucoup on m'a dit vous
regardez rendez vous en terre inconnue
envoyé spécial zones interdites de vol
la série homeland vous auriez fait
veille jo voice vous si vous aviez était
inconnu comme ça vous l'auriez fait ou
pas comme le com et missions non je suis
pas sûr c'est vrai pourquoi c'est parce
que moi j'ai besoin que de pouvoir avoir
à la fois l'image aussi c'est un truc un
peu de comédienne j'ai je sais pas
j'aurais eu du mal je pense que vous
auriez du mal
vous n'aimez pas les ch'tis et les
marseillais sur w9 dans l'amour ce n'est
pas l'amour est dans le pré
et ben non bizarre ça il capte mariages
pour une lune de miel vous détestez
téléfoot ça c'est parce que votre mari
on regarde tout ça me saoule et mes
enfants du nom c'est vrai à tous les
dimanches supporter bien fouet
on n'a pas le droit de parler tout ça
très longtemps vous n'êtes pas mariée
aussi je fais pareil me suis battu et la
messe après téléfoot me régale régal
régalerez galerie